you describe yourself as a classical yes
correct so now what is the difference so
that I can explain it to my people
properly when they say Dave you've
become a libertarian how would you
describe the difference between a
classical liberal liberal and a
libertarian I don't think there is
really such a difference the word
libertarian strictly speaking means an
anarchist it was originally used to
describe communist anarchists of the
Peter Kropotkin variety the problem here
in the United States is the good word
liberal has been hijacked by Social
Democrats and so unlike the European
continent where liberal still means a
believer in private property limited
government little government
intervention individual liberty
pluralism it's now in the United States
come to mean something slightly
different so the word libertarian came
to be used here in the United States to
mean basically what everywhere else
would be called a classical liberal or a
liberal full stop so I don't think there
is that much difference there is perhaps
a slight difference emerging now in as
much as increasingly the word
libertarian does mean something more
radical a bit more extreme so if you say
you're a libertarian you probably imply
that you're either an anarchist or very
close to it if you say you're a
classical liberal you imply that well
you know you're not analysts you do
think there is a necessity government so
you're slightly more moderate so I think
that's what it's like so so I like that
distinction because that's definitely
where I fall I think there is some use
of the state yeah you know as I said I
watched the libertarian party you know
their convention and it was like they're
screaming about you know driver's
licenses and it's like guys you're
really missing the ball here you know
like if we can't just let that go
because there has we're not going even
if you're a hundred percent right
there's no way to really deep construct
an entire system like this is there like
even if even if the returns were purely
purely right is there a way to actually
take a functioning somewhat functioning
society and really well for all the
whole thing not to the political process
really no so like okay Bernie yes so a
bit but yes but no well no the way to if
you what do want to change society in
the longer run the thing to do is to do
it at a grassroots level to create
alternatives to government which i think
is what you should be doing
but I think with the kind of politics
you're describing is rampantly
self-indulgent I would say this is the
kind of politics of a certain kind of
person who is interested in being more
pure than everybody else yeah having an
identity that is not compromising
completely pure it's the same kind of
mentality that leads people to become
religious fundamentalists of one variety
or another it's a desire to be the
person in the group who is right when
everybody else is wrong and so the more
other people move towards your position
the more you're going to insist upon
these really extreme peculiar things
that still make you distinct so I'm
afraid I'm not at all sympathetic to say
yes right I mean it just seems like a
non-starter when they're screaming about
legalizing heroin which we could talk
about the war on drugs which you talk
about a lot and I'd be happy to do that
but when they're going there to start
and driver's licenses start it's like
guys yeah this is know where it is go
for issues where you can persuade the
significant part of the public to come
to your position that's what politics is
about yeah politics is all about
striking a pose and trying to show how
morally pure you are that's just pure
virtue signaling I guess it's
self-indulgent nonsense what you want to
do is make clear what your ultimate
position is but then say well okay on
you go for issues where you can persuade
a significant part of the broad public
that you were right and that yours is
the way to go for and that's where you
go from mainstream issues not fringe
issues like that which may be
interesting for small number of people
but they're not right there's there's a
there's a fun discussion to be had I
suppose about that stuff but not really
a broader absolutely um all right so how
do you decide how much state power is
okay how do you make that distinction
between pure anarchy and I want
something to keep the wheel over here
right they that I think state powers
that's part of it is but it's not really
just that the real distinction is
between what part of your life do you
want to be driven by individual choice
or choices made by voluntary collectives
versus what part of your life do you
want to be determined through some kind
of collective decision-making process
through politics if you like your
government and I think the answer that
if you're a classical liberal you would
give is that you want to maximize the
scope of individual decision making
because that means greater scope for
individual discovery and it also means
that most people are
you would argue the best judges their
own interest so if you allow people to
follow their own judgments what their
actual interests are collectively you'll
end up with the best outcome that
maximizes human welfare so that that
leaves though certain number of areas
where there may be structural problems
it's very difficult to act collectively
in these areas if you want to use the
technical economic terms maybe there's a
public good aspect to what you're
talking about
like national defense and in these areas
it probably does pay to do things
through a collective decision-making
process there's something about these
core areas that means that they are so
important that they have to be on
universally you can't have a situation
where say 90% are covered by the law
enforcement system and 10% are not that
would have all kinds of major negative
effects for the 90% who were covered
nevermind the 10% to who weren't and so
there's a kind of limited range various
way as you do definitely need the
government now I know there are people
who will say oh no you know you could in
theory yes you can do that government
but my own view is that well if that's
the case why isn't everyone going to
Somalia I know people say Somalia is
better off than some of its neighbors
and it's true that if the choices
Anarchy or Pol Pot you will go for Anika
but that doesn't mean that necessarily a
stateless state of affairs is your first
choice right so for all the people that
would say well you know for the the pure
libertarian or whatever you want to call
them at this point that would say no
remove the social safety net altogether
don't don't help the poorest under any
circumstances because if the government
gets out then private entities and
private people will fully fill that void
I suspect that's not you don't believe
that that but well no the thing is I
would ideally like to see a situation
where you don't have the government
providing that function but the trouble
is how do you get from here to there
yeah and the difficulty is if you do
simply withdraw government safety net
provisions fundamental social welfare
transfers it's going to take a long time
probably before you get something that
takes its place and in the meantime a
lot of people are going to suffer quite
severely and I don't think that's
acceptable quite honestly so the
argument should be that you should a
through private action develop non-state
forms of welfare we should revive
mutualism friendly societies fraternal
orders all the great institutions that
we used to have which delivered a huge
range of welfare functions very very
effectively particularly here in the
United States right so we should be
looking to do that privately revive that
but at the same time but we got rid of
those guys distinct well yeah what
happens as the state groups but the Plus
also though it was due to quite concrete
legislative measures particularly ones
urged by the medical profession which
were designed to drive friendly
societies out of health care provision
true what was called lodge practice that
that was a purely legislative function
also crowding out by the state it was
just that the lobby group the doctors
got legislators to pass laws which made
it very very difficult for private
voluntary operation but the other thing
you need to do then back to our original
point is to say that well yes there is
probably going to be a kind of bottom
level provision provided by government
through the political process to ensure
that nobody falls below a certain
minimum level that nobody's stopping the
street people do have a minimal amount
of resources so that they can actually
survive now what you can then do is get
into a highly technical are going about
what the best way of doing this is and
certainly the way we're doing it now in
many Western countries is not the best
way of doing it but that's a minor
argument the major principle I think is
you do concede if are if you're in my
position that there should be some kind
of residual state function of that sort
Singapore probably has the best way of
doing it I would say amongst which is
why well they have a system of for
savings where essentially you are
obliged to pay money into a series of
accounts one of which covers your
healthcare costs mainly in old age one
of which gives you a pension another one
gives you protection against sickness or
unemployment now the crucial difference
between that in the system we have is
that the accounts have your name on it
so it's your money and you make these
for savings into these accounts right
your working life you drawn them when
you need them and if you die let's say
you know you fall under the proverbial
bus yeah all the money you paid in it
becomes part of your estate and last
your heirs
that's incredible now that's a much
better system than the one we have here
that's incredible so it doesn't just get
pulled into something else in mm and
it's your property if you die let's say
you have a large mountain your lell
wouldn't ya be happy with it I'm not
sure about that it is very effective
you've got a large amount in your health
Sammis account to cover the really
expensive part of healthcare which is
looking after you in the last six months
of your life
right but let's say you you die suddenly
from a heart attack you don't like that
yeah then you would have drawn on that
fund and it's there for your heirs it's
part of your estate yeah I mean I'm
completely for that I suspect that the
left you know they would say well no the
state should be able to take that now
you're gone and give it to somebody well
maybe but I mean the point is I think is
I would argue against that for a whole
number of it right but I think that
that's a much better system and say
that's the system they have in Singapore
which also what do they do for the
people that are outside of the system
that we're really all really really poor
the government actually makes
contributions on your behalf but
Singapore is such a successful economy
and society that very very few people
are on such low incomes that they can't
make some contribution and the modular
very low incomes to say either the state
makes contribution is entirely the
minimal level or it tops them up but
that's actually a very best marginal
very small number of people then so if
we wanted to change to a system that was
a little more like that and we've
already hit on this a couple times about
how incremental change is tough but you
don't want to burn it down at the same
time how beyond just making the case for
it you know and I hadn't even heard of
that Singapore thing so now some new
people are going to hear about that
concept how do you actually start making
that happen I mean is that you have to
start doing it at the local level I mean
just get you know the holy that probably
would require a change in the national
level because you're talk about
something which should replace the way
Social Security is currently run you
have a switched Social Security from a
pay-as-you-go system to a fully funded
system of this this kind that would
require action by Congress or the very
least maybe by state legislatures for
some of the other forms I think you just
need to make the political case for it
and the difficulty of course is that you
have a whole bunch of people in the
existing system who can't simply be
switched over to the new one so you're
going to have a period of about 30 years
certainly 20 years where there's an
overlap where you have the new system in
place and you have people who are under
the old system that's inevitable it
seems to me and that means in the short
run this could be quite costly but I
think the long run well worth doing yeah
interesting so I heard you in a video
that I saw you do yesterday talk about
how how libertarians are generally
thought of as non interventionist yeah
you think they're although I don't think
you prescribe to it you think there is a
situation where a libertarian could be
for some
you know intervention basically you
clean them okay that the for any kind of
libertarian classical liberal the
question with foreign policy is which
course of action is going to most
maximize Liberty both in the country
that is potentially doing the
intervening in this case the US for
example and the part of the world where
the intervention might take place now
that should be the guiding principle
behind what your foreign policy is now
what I would say and I agree with friend
of mine Randy Barnett on this is he's
been on the show there's nothing
inherent or necessary about libertarian
principles that means you must be a non
interventionist what I would argue and
they're here perhaps I disagree psych
with Randy is that the number of cases
where the benefits Liberty will be so
great that you would support
intervention is actually very very
slight you I would apply something like
a just war principle you have to show
that really the benefit is bound to
exceed the cost and that the this is
knowable and that the intervention could
be done in a way that doesn't
systematically violate the human rights
so that that's quite a high bar yeah
wait let's quasi for a sec how much does
the benefit have to be for you and your
society not just the people that you're
potentially doing well I think the small
matter of the cost because if you think
about intervention in foreign parts the
world them one of the main arguments
against that from a libertarian or
classical liberal position is that it
actually is bad for Liberty back home in
the country during the intervening to
the extent that the United States
becomes an empire and it is an empire
that's not possible about this that
undermines Republican institutions and
Liberty back home and this is not a new
phenomenon the many of the things that
led to the growth of the state in Great
Britain were because of British
intervention outside the rest the world
the India Office which ran the Indian
empire was our first big modern
Department of State and then transformed
the rest of government by its example so
basically you've made you do these
things over there wherever there is and
then you actually have more state power
at well under that is provides an
example so in order to have for example
you need to really large military he'd
be going to have a kind of global
interventionist role that inevitably
does things like increase the role of
military domestically increases its
purchasing power it's cloud builds up
the military-industrial complex that
Eisenhower warned against has all kinds
of bad effects it also leads to growth
of a surveillance state it leads to the
growth of the police power of the state
which we spoke about earlier which you
might say is necessary in certain cases
but certainly not to the degree but it
now and it just also generally gives our
rulers ideas above their station because
if you have the mindset that oh we can
go over and be this benevolent despots
and transform the lives of these people
in other parts of the world this tends
to naturally create a mindset we think
where there's these people here in our
own society they could do it our
benevolent interference as well and
that's a very dangerous mindset right
and somehow we always have money to do
those adventures but we never have money
yet and elsewhere it's happening yet
what a surprise yeah what I'd be
happening there you know it benefits all
kinds of people that mean the other
quite shameful thing is that this
typically involves sending young men
from often poor backgrounds into harm's
way when the children of the people
making these decisions are certainly not
joining the military and if they are
they're probably not going to be sent
into harm's way in that way which i
think is seriously disreputable so i
think i wouldn't rule out that there are
certain cases where an intervention
could be on balance beneficial for
liberty both at home and in the place
where the intervention takes place but I
think that's vanishingly very low
probability that very few cases like
that in my view right so let's let's
just take Syria for example because
that's obviously the the big one at
element we know over 400,000 people are
dead you know this thing is not ending
anytime soon it's hard to know who's
side we're on what's going on with Iran
and Russia all of that stuff now I think
the main the mainstream libertarian
think would be even if we partly created
this mess we just got to cut our losses
and let it be how do you how does epics
and morality get involved as a classical
liberal where you see okay we don't want
to be killing more people but it may be
we could create humanitarian corridors
or maybe there's a way to do some good
there but it may not be cost-effective
for us the question is who are the
actors in this thing because people
always say okay we've got to do
something or what should we do who is
the we in this sentence
now I think people get two things
confused and calculated one is what
should civil society do what should or
can we do as individuals and there all
kinds of things we can depending on what
you think is the right course of action
but the other thing of course it means
is what should our government the
government of the United States the
United Kingdom whatever do now in terms
of what governments should do
governments in this context are
basically the purveyors of deadly force
which is their core function and so the
question therefore I think is slightly
different and really you want to
minimize harm it seems to me now I would
argue that actually the course of action
that will minimize harm in most cases is
classic foreign policy realism because
what you want to do is to minimize the
chances of war and large-scale conflict
and I think actually channeling Bismarck
is probably the way to go strange thing
for a liberal say right but I do think
in foreign policy asking yourself the
question what would Bismarck do is
probably a good way to go because
foreign policy realists like bhisma do
not generally cause large scale Wars and
that's what you want to do we can look
at what the government should do you're
looking to try and minimize the amount
of armed conflict that happens sure so
what do you what would Bismarck do in a
situation that's already begun only
populate for us now so they'll still say
up but is there is there a moral cost I
guess is what my question is is there a
moral cost of knowing that something
horrible is happening and that perhaps
you could do something I again is who's
the you okay so I think is this yeah the
question is this if you're saying
there's something terrible going on
there I feel a kind of moral
responsibility as a human being for the
suffering of my fellow human beings that
part of the world all kinds of things
you can do you could give money to a
non-government organization or a charity
some of that medicine some frontier
you might even volunteer to work with
MSF as a dot if you're a doctor or
paramedic you might support things like
the creation of Lobby the government in
Syria the competence to allow people to
leave non-comp civilians to lead the
combat don't see spires you might argue
for if you on the other hand you might
say well I think that this is the right
side in this conflict and if you feel
strongly about it pick up a gun and go
and fight that that's the honest and
honorable thing to do right or give
money to you know help people acquire
mercenaries or things
now the other hand if the government is
what you're talking about my argument is
that typically government intervention
military intervention by states in
conflicts of this kind is almost always
going to make the conflict more
intractable more bloody more extensive
more long-lasting and it's not going to
be ultimately the interest even of the
outside powers so much this is driven by
the desire to avoid the other side
getting on top and so you know the
realist view there is well usually steer
clear and that's a vital national
interest is at stake you do not get
involved because both on pragmatic
Machiavellian grounds but also on moral
grounds because if you intervene this is
very likely to make the whole conflict
worse than the otherwise would be right
it's also Syria I mean let me - others
work in the case of Syria I predicted
when the Arab Spring was going on that
it came to Syria it would be a bloodbath
now this didn't require great prescience
of my kind my part because the whole
point about Syria is that the government
is dominated by a clan stroke religious
sect than desire ease the ala bites
which is what asset comes from who come
from the mountain region of Latakia
virtually all of the other people in
Syria particularly the Sunni or Sunni
Muslims regard them as rank heretics
that means that a democratic regime in
Syria is probably not feasible at the
moment because if Assad and the alibis
give up power right now you're dead yeah
and they're not so they're not going to
do it so I knew there would be armed
resistance to any movement - or the
state now once the Civil War started the
question is what you do the problem I
think as far as Western policy goes is
that a large part of Western policy has
been to try and overthrow Assad but they
have willed the end without willing the
means they've intervened but the
intervention has actually been of a kind
that has simply made the conflict more
intractable and gone on longer and it's
provoked countervailing intervention by
the Iranians and the Russians who for
their own strategic reasons don't want
to see outside overthrown so that shows
how government intervention can actually
make a conflict that probably would have
ended one way or another much more
intractable my own view actually thought
it's worth is that the only really
effective way of resolving that conflict
is to partition Syria into three or four
states I think that's the only way to
actually do it yeah I mean incredibly Jo
Biden when he was running for president
when he ended up being abominable rush
there should be an actual Kurdish nation
in the cell the soon you should have a
nation the she and all that and people
laughed at him because it sounded
sounded very academic and we're not
going to split these countries but at
this point Syria is not really amazing
states believe that's a perfectly
rational solution he was completed much
about that yeah anybody who looks at
that part of the world and it's a
political realist is going to say that
partitioning several of these states
that were created totally artificially
by the British and the French yeah
during World War had even an Geographic
line I mean really on ridiculous lines
in the sand as the famous book calls it
yeah you know those states are not
viable they should really be broken up
and that's that would be a rational
humane response to the situation we now
have yeah I don't want to spend a ton of
time in this because we don't have it
how much how much of what's going on the
Middle East is just because of the guys
that were drawing up and if you look at
a country like Jordan it looks
ridiculous the shape of Jordan is absurd
it looks like a puzzle piece that got
angled I mean how much is just that the
people actually drawing the map had
nothing to do with what was happening on
the ground Allah and I do by the way I
don't blame you guys solely for that
because the Ottoman Empire ran out of it
for a long what means seriously we have
you talked to most Turks what they will
say pretty quickly is that things were
working a lot better they when they ran
it might read turkish view if if france
britain had followed the ottomans and
used the ottoman local government units
things might well have worked out better
because those units actually reflected
under underlying realities many cases
but no that's part of the problem part
of the problem in there as in large
areas of africa is that you have
political units which do not make
demographic sense but it's not just that
i think there are other factors as well
there's been a collapse in the in the
government in that huge area the world
central africa up through the middle
east a slight libya for example what has
happened is that the state the political
order has collapsed and what we're
seeing is lots of violence caused by
non-state actors basically clans gangs
tribes terrorist groups we call them
terrorist groups so you might have all
them criminal gangs that's what they are
basically
and until some kind of stable political
order is recreated in that part of world
I don't see that state of chaos ending
anytime soon the problem is that the
existing political order and this is
where those guys Sykes and picot come in
is simply not sustainable because it's
based on an irrational thing the other
thing that's going on there is that
basically you've had very very rapid
population growth in that part of the
world in the last 30 to 40 years
probably more than that region can
sustain ecologically and you have an
economy in large parts of that region
which is a very badly run because it's
corruption of incompetent government's
and B is very dependent upon oil and
what you have now is lots and lots of
unemployed but over educated young men
and that is always and everywhere a
recipe for trouble
right it's fertile ground for terrorists
I mean II can read your minds young yeah
is there a little saving grace in that
because of the internet now and that
information can spread so fast that
these people are learning there's other
ways of life and that maybe that
ultimately will be what allows them to
as they get older to create societies
that'll be a little more egalitarian so
I think I think I am optimistic in the
longer term in the short term I'm a
pessimist I'm afraid in the longer a
medium term I'm not to miss for the
world and for most of the world because
I do think that things like that mean
that the world is going to become more
interconnected people are going to be
more aware of different ways of doing
things I do work back to what we spoke
about earlier they'll realize that their
identity is not something they're stuck
with that they can actually shape their
own life more but I think it's going to
be a while before we get them afraid
you